- Welcome back y'all,
Kelsey Grammer is back here with us.
(audience cheers)
So earlier we sang the theme
song to his reboot of Frasier,
which you can now see on Paramount+,
the theme song is a classic
and as are many other theme
songs from great TV shows.
So it's time to see how
well we will know some
of those shows and
songs with a game called
Tossed Salad and Scrambled Eggs.
♪ Tossed salad and scrambled eggs ♪
(audience applauds)
- Yeah!
Oh lord, are you there?
(majestic orchestral music)
- [God] Alpha and Omega
is in the house, y'all.
Now listen Kelsey, you need a spokesperson
for the Faith American Brewing Company.
I'm your guy.
- Okay.
Here's what we're gonna do with this game.
I'm gonna give you a clue that has to do
with a famous theme song
for a famous TV show.
And all you have to do is hit your button
and tell me the name of the TV show,
All right?
- Okay.
And if you lose, don't blame me.
Blame the other guy. Okay, let's go.
- Okay, not today, Satan. Yeah.
- [God] Here's your first one.
- Okay.
- [God] Before his life
was turned upside down,
he spent most of his days
in West Philly where he was-
- Oh yeah.
I was like, it's Will Smith?
It's Fresh Prince of Bel Air.
- [God] It is the Fresh Prince of Bel Air
- [Kelly] Yes!
- [God] Kelly got yourself a point.
- I did have a feeling that
if this wasn't my decade,
I wouldn't have a chance in hell.
- Okay.
- [God] Well Kelly, you in the lead so far
with one single point,
we got ourselves a game
Here is the next question.
- Why you diminish it?
Why, why?
- That's what God does.
(Kelly laughs)
- He does not he does-
- I gotta keep you humble.
I gotta keep you humble.
- Well yeah.
Here's your next clue.
- Okay.
Of this blended family.
The youngest one wore curls in her hair.
(bell rings)
- Brady Bunch
- Kelsey.
(bell chimes)
- It is The Brady Bunch.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you,
- That's an older show
I don't really remember that,
but I thought there was
probably gonna be a show, so.
I guessed.
- Oh you got it.
- [God] We got ourselves a tie.
Yes indeed. Alright,
here's your next question.
- Okay.
- [God] There are times
you'd like to be in a place
where everybody knows your name.
Kelsey.
- If you didn't get that,
it would've been real sad.
- Cheers.
- It is Cheers.
- That would've been real sad.
- [God] Such a big fan.
I remember a season two
episode 16 of Frasier
that aired February 21st, 1995.
That's the one where Sam showed up.
- That's my birthday,
but I wasn't in that one.
- Oh!
- [God] I remember like it was yesterday.
Happy birthday.
- Thank you.
For all time.
- And bless you
Thank you, thank you God
- [God] Okay, here's the next question.
- Around his community.
It was always a beautiful
day in the neighborhood.
(bell rings)
Kelly
- Oh I was so quick.
- Did you see that?
- That was pretty good, Yeah.
Mister Rogers.
- Yeah,
- It was Mister Rogers.
- It was like a cat!
- So that was good, that was good.
- It Was like a cat, like
a ninja. Like ninja speed.
- [God] We got a tie, we got a tie.
Fred Rogers was a saint, he was a saint.
And if you want to go to
the neighborhood of make
belief now, just go on Twitter.
Okay here's your next question.
When things are going your way,
it feels like you're just moving
on up straight to the top.
(bell rings)
Kelsey
- The Jeffersons
- [God] It is the The Jeffersons.
- That's a good theme song.
- That was a good theme song,
- That's a great one
- That was a great theme song.
- [God] Okay, here is your next question.
Family is important, but in
this show, everywhere you looked
and every place you went,
♪ Everywhere you look,
everywhere you, it's in the ♪
Is it Family Matters?
(buzzer rings)
- Oh, oh, I'm sorry it
is not Family Matters
♪ Days go by ♪
- Fabulous, but still.
- Is that the same song?
- [Audience] No!
- No but think about it.
(audience laughs)
- It's the, well think about it though.
I just sang the same melody.
Hey, step by step.
- They do that a lot though, too.
♪ Step by step ♪
Oh my God. I can't believe I didn't-
- [God] You know what, Kelly,
I'm gonna give you a point,
just for that performance.
That was wonderful.
(bell rings)
- I like that.
- [God] And it was Full House.
Of course it was Full House.
- So what show is that?
- Full House
Whatever happened to predictability-
- Oh Full House,
yeah no that wasn't my show.
- Milkman, the paper boy,
- evening TV, missed your
old familiar friends,
(bullhorn sounds)
when you're just around the bend.
- Okay got it.
- [God] Well, I'm sorry to cut you off
like that Kelly, but
my therapist says that
that sound means time's up.
- Oh, okay.
- Oh.
- [God] So here's your last question.
- Even God has a therapist, okay.
Yeah
- That's right
- [God] I got a lot on
my mind, let me tell you.
Okay, this one is worth a
hundred points. Why not?
Okay, here we go.
The most meaningful thing you
can tell someone is simply
thank you for being a friend.
(bell rings)
Kelsey
- Oh!
- Girlfriends, no, no, no (beep)
Sorry, sorry. No, no, no, no, no, no.
It's The Golden girls.
(bell rings)
- [God] Golden Girls.
- [Kelly] Girlfriends!
Oh my God.
- Golden Girls, yeah.
- I am forever calling
Golden Girl's girlfriends.
That's my favorite.
Ah, be sure you-
I love that win for you.
- Yeah.
- Be sure to watch Frasier
on Paramount+ everybody.